Uh,
Sean has a really amazing bio.
We're lucky to have him here with us today for the other side series.
Um,
he is a UCLA medical school professor and the founder at the executive director
of the Ucla Center for digital behavior and the UC Institute for prediction
technology.
He has a phd in psychology and a Master's in health services research from
Stanford University.
And the work he will present today is on behavior change based on his research
with paste for the patients and consulting with businesses.
He's tackled challenges ranging from getting people to stick with New Year's
resolutions,
which we all would love to learn more about,
I'm sure to a keeping healthier and addressing some of the most important would
be problems like preventing the spread of HIV.
His book stick with it,
uh,
is available from Harper as of June 20th.
Thank you for being here.
Okay,
thanks so much Jessica.
I wrote this book because on a daily basis I was hearing stories from people who
were having trouble sticking with things that they wanted to do.
For those of you who've,
who've ever tried to do something and it had a difficult time sticking with
things,
it can be really,
really tough.
You know,
if you've tried doing something and you fail at it and you really want to do it,
people can really suffer whether we're trying to do it for ourselves to get
ourselves to stick with things or we're trying to get other people who we really
care about to stick with things that they want to do or that are good for them.
So,
so when hearing these stories,
I'd really empathize with people and,
and at the same time,
you know,
half the time I'd be empathizing with them and half the time I'd be really
frustrated hearing their answers because they're their reasoning behind why they
couldn't stick with things or why other people couldn't stick with things.
We're often because someone wasn't dedicated enough,
they were lazy,
they,
there were problems with the individual,
they weren't motivated enough.
And you know,
this not only makes us feel bad about ourselves or about people to pin that on
the individual,
but it's actually not the correct science.
It's not backed by science.
So what I had learned is that
the reason why we don't stick with things is not because of a problem with the
person,
not not because of problem with ourselves or other people.
It's because we're not following the right process.
So in this talk,
I'm going to talk about that process and,
and that's what led me to write this book.
And this same process can be used for no small mundane things,
just like getting ourself to stick with a hobby that we want to take on.
But it can also be used for really serious important things like getting
ourselves or others to stick with medication that's been prescribed or getting
ourselves or others to stay free from diseases.
So that's why I wrote this book.
Now
as a social and behavioral psychologist,
I love that I get to,
to me it and help so many different types of people.
I get to meet with entrepreneurs,
with public health experts,
with engineers in our own research participants.
And on the way over here,
for example,
on the flight over,
I got,
I got into conversation with the person in the seat next to me and he,
he reminds me of my uncle sid from New York.
He has this strong New York accent and,
and so he says to me,
Dr Yung,
every month I pay for my gym membership.
I,
I tried to do something good for myself.
I know I should go to the gym,
but I don't go to the gym.
Why don't I go,
I'm paying for my gym membership.
Can you give me some drugs or analyze my dreams to help me?
But I have to tell him,
no,
I can't because that's not what I do.
I help people change their behavior.
But his problem is one that I think a lot of us can relate to.
The problem of,
you know,
how do we stick to things?
And I know I,
a few years ago,
I planned by the end of the summer,
I plan to learn basics of speaking Chinese.
But at the end of the summer,
all I could say was,
yeah,
I'll have the kung pao chicken please.
Now now problems like this or are not just about personal behaviors like wanting
to learn a new language or or stick with things,
they also applied to business.
So a team in your organization may have plans to complete work by a deadline,
but,
but then they keep missing their deadlines,
but they plan their own deadlines.
Now the,
the typical solution to things like this or the reasoning behind it is to say
that the person is flawed,
that the person doesn't have enough willpower,
the person isn't motivated enough and we need to change the person.
But that only,
you know,
it not only makes us feel badly about ourselves as people with with putting
blame like that,
but it's not the correct science.
So,
so what I've learned is that we just need to know that there are three different
types of behaviors.
Once we know those three types of behaviors,
there are a set of tools for changing those three types of behaviors.
So that's what we're going to go over in this talk.
Now,
when you walked in,
you should have received a a card.
Hopefully raise your hand right now if you didn't get a,
if you didn't get a card in and we can get someone to get your card right now.
Great.
Thanks so much.
Uh,
so on the card I want to ask you to write down a behavior that you want to
change.
This can be a,
a personal behavior,
like getting yourself to read more books or,
or to be more engaged in work.
Um,
it can be a business type behavior,
like getting your employees to take better care of their health.
Make sure to write it down because toward the end I'm going to call on some of
you to talk about your behavior and we'll call someone up here actually.
All right.
How many of you have had the situation where you are trying to get something
out?
You're trying to talk and someone keeps interrupting you?
Think probably all of us have read.
All of us have experienced that.
Now.
How many of you get frustrated when you're,
when you're trying to talk in the person keeps frustrating you.
Okay,
well it may not be that person's fault.
So that person may be doing what I call an automatic behavior.
So an automatic behavior is something where we're not even aware of what we're
doing.
It just happens unconsciously.
And knowing that something is an automatic behavior allows us to know how to
address it.
So other examples of an automatic behavior are forgetting that we're not
standing up straight eating food that's just sitting in front of us without even
being aware of what we're doing.
Those are automatic behaviors.
But once we know that some things,
an automatic behavior,
there are a set of tools and strategies that we can use to change it.
But before we get into that,
let's talk about the second type of behavior.
Well,
while waiting at a stoplight to cross the street,
I'd often pull out my phone check email to burn some time and sometimes I'd even
cross the street while I'm still reading the email.
That's not always the best idea.
It can lead to accidents.
It can lead me tripping in the middle of the street.
I shouldn't be doing that.
But,
but I feel like
I wasn't able to stop.
You know,
I,
I felt like I had to just finish reading this email and then I put the phone
away.
So this is an example of what I call a burning behavior.
Birding behaviors.
Well,
automatic behaviors or things that unconsciously,
automatically burning behaviors are behaviors where we're aware of what we're
doing,
but we feel powerless to stop.
We feel like we just can't stop.
So in my case,
knowing that it was a burning behavior,
I was able to stop it.
And part of that solution comes from every week.
Now I take a digital day of rest.
So from Friday to Saturday,
I don't use any apps.
I don't check email,
I don't even talk about work.
It's just time for friends and family.
And I was able to,
to address that and to,
to stop what could be a growing digital addiction because I knew this was a
burning behavior.
But before we get into that,
let me tell you about the last type of behavior
and also go into with this the,
the background of how I came to study this.
So this is my brother up here,
and when I was in graduate school,
just down the street here at Stanford,
my brother came up to visit.
Now he had been suffering from an intestinal disorder called Crohn's disease and
he came up to visit and he was just in too much pain to go back home.
So we brought him to the emergency room
and they looked at him and it turns out his intestines had burst.
So he was rushed into emergency surgery and
they saved his life.
He was minutes away from dying.
They said they saved his life.
So we spent,
spent two weeks recovering at Stanford Hospital,
then he was prescribed daily medication advice to change his lifestyle and a,
and then he was released.
Now,
now try to put yourself in my brother's situation the way that I did.
You just,
you just almost died and you've been told change your lifestyle.
How likely do you,
do you guys think you would be to do that?
I mean,
if you're like my brother,
if you're like most people,
you'd say,
I'm going to change.
I'm going to eat differently.
I'm going to exercise.
I'm going to take my medication,
I'm going to do everything that I'm supposed to do.
And my brother said he'd do that 100%
but he didn't.
I didn't understand why I,
my family and I were really close.
I love my brother.
So I was on the phone with my mom for hours every day and we were trying to
figure out,
you know,
what could we do to get him to follow these recommendations?
Why wasn't he doing it?
I was scared for him.
I was,
I was worried.
I was confused and I was frustrated and so I started searching for answers.
I started talking to all different types of people,
experts in education,
in medicine,
in business,
and I was trying to find answers that I kept finding.
I kept finding the same one size fits all solution answers.
People were saying he needed to have more willpower.
People were saying he needed to be more educated about crones and how to change
it.
They were saying that that he wasn't motivated enough about his health but this,
but he's my brother's smart,
he's motivated,
he's health conscious,
he's educated,
so these answers didn't make sense to me and so that's why I started studying
this area and after 15 years of studying it,
I've come up with some answers.
So what I figured out is it's not about a one size fits all solution and it's
not about blaming the individual.
What we need to know is that
not all behaviors are the same.
There are three types of behaviors.
You know,
I found while I was questioning my brothers,
while I was questioning why my brother wasn't changing,
other things were happening at the same time in my life.
I was in a band and and trying to figure out how do we get,
how do we get the fans of our band to keep coming back to our shows to keep
buying albums.
I was teaching classes at Stanford and wondering why was it that the students in
our classes would wait until the day of paper was due and then they'd asked for
more time or I was wondering how could I get myself where I was working on so
many different things to stay engaged and motivated and doing all of them.
Now all of these seem like really different things,
but on this,
if you look deeper there,
they're actually United by one common thread and that's how do we get people to
stick with things.
So people often,
often we're even planning what they were going to do,
but they still kept failing.
So how do we get people to stick with things?
Well,
what I've found is that we need to know the three types of behaviors.
So the three types of behaviors or automatic burning and common behaviors are
what I call the abcs of behavior.
So I'll do a quick recap about that.
Automatic behaviors are behaviors that happen unconsciously,
like the example of the interrupter
burning behaviors,
burning behaviors or behaviors that,
that are not happening unconsciously.
But we feel powerless to stop.
Addictions are often burning behaviors.
And then third are common behaviors.
Common behaviors are the most common of all behaviors.
Common behaviors are often due to motivation.
So,
um,
common behavior is something where we're aware of what we're doing,
but the risks of doing it or the energy that it takes for us to do it isn't
worth the benefits we think we might get from doing it.
So let me,
let me say that again.
I'll repeat that.
Common behavior is something where the energy that it takes for us to do
something or the,
the risks that it takes for us to do it,
is it worth the benefit we think we might get from doing it.
So let me give an example cause that's,
that's a lot.
So my brothers,
my brothers lifestyle change was an example of a common behavior
because despite being told that he should change his lifestyle and that may keep
them out of the hospital,
he didn't think it was worth it to change.
Why should he,
why should he give up things that he loved doing?
Why should he change the way he eats?
Why should he exercise more,
meditate,
take medication?
Why should you do these things if there wasn't even a guarantee that it would
work?
That's a common behavior.
But knowing that something's a common behavior
or an arb behavior allows us to know how to fix it.
We just need to know the set of tools for fixing those types of behaviors.
Yeah,
so this set of tools or what I call the forces of behavior change.
Now you guys,
you guys have may have learned in physics that there are forces that move
objects and move objects can't move this.
There are forces that move objects in certain directions.
Well,
there are behavioral forces that move people.
They get us to behave in certain ways
now just as a flight crew or a pilot or aerospace engineers need to know the
physical forces that move a plane in order to fly it safely.
All of us need to know the behavioral forces that move people so we can behave
the way we want.
There are seven of these forces.
So what I did,
I came up with a framework called science where each one of these,
each one,
the letters of science represents a different,
one of the seven forces and it's called science because it's not because you
need a scientist to to know it,
but because it's based on decades of scientific research.
So
s stands for stepladders.
Okay,
we know we're supposed to do things in small,
but we often don't.
We often don't plan small steps to change our behavior.
A few weeks ago I ran into someone at the market and he was a cross country
runner in high school and he decided that he wanted to run a marathon.
He ran cross country in high school so he knew how to run,
but he hadn't run since then.
Then you know it had been 20 years since then and he decides,
I'm just going to go run this marathon and I'm going to do it.
I've got,
I've got the motivation,
I've got the energy,
I can do this.
Any actually did pretty well.
You got to mile 19 but then he collapsed and he said,
I didn't finish that marathon and I'm probably not going to run another marathon
again.
Now that story,
you know,
I don't know about for you guys,
but there's no way I could run a marathon without training for it,
so,
so this makes a lot of sense.
If we want to be able to do something,
if we want to stick to things,
we need to start in small incremental steps,
but just like the marathon example,
we often make the same mistakes in our own life.
If we want to be able to make a new year's resolution to go to the gym,
we'll say,
I'm going to go to the gym.
I haven't really been at all before this past year,
but I'm going to go five days a week for the next year and that's a pretty tall
order.
So we need to think about things in small steps.
But the question is how do you know what a small step is?
How do you know how small a step should be?
So I created this,
this figure here called steps,
goals,
and dreams.
Now the idea is the marathon example.
If,
if I was going to try to run a marathon,
I've never run one before,
I'm not going to be able to do it in a week,
I'm not going to be able to do it in a month,
probably probably take me a few months of training to run a marathon.
So that's what I call a dream.
It's attainable,
but it takes some time to get there.
If I want something now to do a first step would be something that takes less
than a week.
So getting a pair of running shoes,
maybe a first step,
or if I haven't run before,
much running for 10 1520 minutes,
just something small would be a first step.
So this,
this figure will teach us how we can plan steps that are the right size so that
we don't give up.
Okay,
so that's step ladders.
C stands for community.
We all want to be different from the crowd.
We want to be different than other individuals,
but our social environment matters.
It matters a lot more than we even think it does.
And there's a science how to leverage social to create change.
Okay.
One of the that we do in
our research,
I created what's called the hope intervention.
Hope intervention is an online community where it's designed to motivate people
to change their behavior.
We invite people to a 12 week intervention and we've found that these
interventions to change people's behavior across different areas,
drug use,
HIV,
different types of behaviors.
We find that within 12 weeks we can get people to change their behavior and it
leverages the,
the force of community through these online communities.
We find that that people in our hope interventions are about two to three times
as likely to change their behavior.
Now I stands for important
people won't do things unless they want to do it unless they're motivated.
Right?
Yes,
but no,
not necessarily.
Motivation definitely matters and that's why it's up here as one of these seven
forces,
but people actually don't need to be motivated in order to stick with things.
So I'll give an example from the the hope intervention that I was mentioning.
We did,
we did a whole intervention on trying to get people at high risk for HIV to get
an HIV test.
They weren't interested in getting an HIV test.
We just,
we had him sign up for an,
for our group.
They took a survey,
we paid them to take a survey and then we said,
all right,
you guys are free to go.
You don't need to be in this community anymore.
It was up to us to keep them engaged,
keep them motivated.
Well,
by the end of the study
we had people in,
in our hope group were much more likely two to three times as likely as people
who were to test for HIV.
They still didn't even,
wasn't,
we're an interested necessarily in testing,
but we got them to test.
So the point is
important in motivation matters.
But if we're using the other forces,
we can often get people to do things even if they're not motivated to do that
thing themselves.
Now e stands for easy.
If we can make something easier for people to do,
then for them not to do it or easier for ourselves to do than to not do people
do it.
It's that simple.
Yeah.
Just like,
like,
uh,
we can,
we can get people to,
to do easy things by changing around our environment.
We can do that with behaviors.
In this chapter on easy,
I talk about some business examples of how businesses were able to make things
easy.
So have you guys who's heard the story of Joe Column B?
So if you guys ask someone,
ask someone about the story of [inaudible].
Let's see what,
what,
uh,
what time is it?
Oh,
we've got,
okay,
we've got time.
Let me tell you this story.
It's a good story.
So Joe,
column B,
and uh,
this was took place in 1958 in the late 1950s.
He had graduated from Stanford School of business from the GSB and he went to go
work for a company called Owl Rexall.
Aloe Rexall was a,
is a grocery chain,
grocery store chain.
And what they told them is,
hey Joe,
we want you to go off on your own and start this new chain of stores called
Pronto.
So he starts pronto.
But pronto was struggling.
He wasn't doing well.
The reason is there was this other competitor grocery store that had just come
out and they were doing really well.
They were called seven 11.
So seven 11 was open at unprecedented hours.
They were open.
7:00 AM to 11:00 PM they were offering all kinds of products.
Joe and Pronto couldn't compete.
So our Rexall said it's not working.
Let's ax Prompto and,
and we'll,
we'll do something else,
Joe.
But Joe didn't want to do that.
He left.
He left work from Al Rexall and he mortgaged his house and decides he's going to
go on his own and saved Pronto,
but he didn't know how to do it.
So,
so he says,
okay,
I'm going to take a vacation.
Meanwhile I'm going to go to the Caribbean and,
and think this over while he's in the Caribbean,
he's relaxing,
he's laying by the beach.
People would bring into my ties.
He's,
he's drinking,
they're bringing him food,
he's listening to Calypso and reggae music there.
And he realizes this is a pretty sweet setup for someone who's on vacation.
They're making it pretty easy for tourists to be here.
Maybe there's something that I can do with this,
this lifestyle with this making it easy and I can bring this back to pronto.
So that's what he does.
So he goes back home and in compared to competitor stores,
which were offering 10 different types of Manet's,
13 types of bread,
you know,
a ton of different product choices.
Joe Decides I'm going to have just one.
I'm going to make it easy for people.
When they come in here,
they're going to know what they can purchase.
And it worked.
It worked.
People started not only coming in to to his stores,
but they kept on buying and it kept on working and,
and pronto stores,
which ultimately changed their name,
became a huge lasting success.
They're still around today.
Anyone know?
Anyone have an idea of what the store chain is?
You got to say a ladder trader Joe's.
Exactly.
So his name was Joe.
They're inspired by the trip to the Caribbean.
So now when you,
you see the Hawaiian shirts,
it's from the story of Joe.
Now Trader Joe's isn't the only one to leverage this force of easy.
Think about Amazon.
You know,
Amazon prime,
Amazon Dash make shopping easy.
You don't even delete.
You don't have to leave your home.
I mean we,
I don't go shopping anywhere anymore.
Just everything on Amazon now they can deliver to you before you even know what
you want to order.
That's pretty easy.
Google,
you guys have actually done it too.
And,
and with some of you in the group,
you may be a may have been involved in this.
So,
so Google,
as you guys know,
I'm one of the founding tenants.
One of the benefits of Google is that there's food everywhere.
Well that also can lead to the Google 15 or Google 20 right?
And so Google found that their employees were not as healthy as they would like.
So they decided we're going to change around the dining halls and make it so
that we're going to take the unhealthier foods and put it in the back and make
them in containers that aren't clear anymore.
Had a big effect on employee behavior and unhealth and on eating.
So the force of easy is a powerful way to change people's behavior.
Next n stands for neuro hacks,
neuro hack,
sir,
quick mental shortcuts that can get us to change our behavior.
So just like hitting control,
alt delete on a PC can allow us to use a program that was jammed up or reset
things.
Neuro hacks allow us to reset our brain and allow us to,
to think and behave in ways that we couldn't before.
I'll give an example of a neuro hacking in the chapter on neuro hacks.
I mentioned a story by a man named Marissa.
So Maricio was,
was a designer and he was in a funk,
though he had just gotten a divorce.
He didn't feel like motivated to be a designer anymore.
He didn't feel like going to work,
but he didn't know what to do.
But he got an idea while he was at work one day and he came across to the
familiar screen of,
of it's flashing in front of him saying,
you need to change your password.
And he says,
I'm going to use my password to change my life and get me out of this funk.
So what does he do?
So he says,
I'm going to change my password to the number four.
Get her,
forget her,
forget her.
So,
uh,
or sorry,
not for,
forgive her,
forgive her.
I forgive her.
I forget.
So forgive her.
So he decides I'm going to every day I have to type,
forgive her.
And that'll get me to be able to forgive,
forgive for what's happened.
And when you first started doing it,
it was pretty difficult.
You know,
you can imagine he's going through this divorce is having a tough time and now
he has to type forgive her.
So the first few times it was difficult,
but what he found is that as he kept typing,
forgive her,
it became easier to do.
He didn't have these,
these terrible feelings that he thought he would.
He didn't have to change his password to something else.
He could continue doing this and it just reset his brain and made him think I'm
getting over her.
I am.
I'm forgiving her.
I'm forgetting and I'm moving on.
And he has moved on since that was,
it was a neuro hack that allows him to,
to move on.
But,
but he didn't just stop there.
He also,
he was smoking and he,
he changed his password to quit smoking.
And he said,
you told me that you quit smoking overnight.
Five years later.
He hasn't been smoking since.
That's the power of neuro hacks.
C stands for captivating.
Yeah.
We know that we should reward ourselves.
We should reward people for,
for doing things in order to,
to create lasting change.
But rewards don't always work.
Think about the gamification gamification fad,
which has kind of fizzled out.
So rewards work but not,
oh is because not all types of rewards work.
Not everyone's motivated by points and badges and leaderboards out.
We need not just any reward,
but we need a reward that's truly captivating.
It's gotta be important to people.
Different things are motivating to different people.
So this chapter,
we'll talk about the history and there's a long history going back about a
hundred years of,
of how to motivate change and how to create rewards.
This chapter,
we'll talk about it
finally,
he stands for ingrained,
or Barack Obama was known for,
for making a routine out of the clothes that he wore,
the food that he ate so that he could save time for making important decisions
about our country.
Mark Zuckerberg,
he was known for,
or he has a 20 versions of the same shirt writer,
Ernest Hemingway.
He writes,
he was known for writing every day at the same time.
In the morning,
if you make something,
a routine,
it becomes easier to do and it gets ingrained in our brain.
So those are,
those are the seven forces.
That's the,
the science framework.
And now all we need to do is,
is no,
now that we know the,
the ABC is,
we know the three types of behaviors and we know the seven forces,
we just need to know which of the seven forces do we use and when,
so I created a,
a simple two step model.
It's pretty easy.
You're just step one,
identify whether something is in a,
B or c behavior.
And second,
apply the forces needed to change that type of behavior.
So this is,
this is what I call the science of lasting change.
And here's,
here's the figure.
You can see that first there's automatic behaviors,
burning behaviors and common behaviors.
Automatic behaviors were not aware of what we're doing.
So there's,
there's no brain and the stick figures had burning behaviors where we're a
little bit more aware.
Um,
and then common behaviors,
we're fully aware.
So,
and,
and as you can see,
the,
the seven forces are listed down at the bottom and the more stars next to that
force,
the more important it is for changing that type of behavior.
You know,
in general as we get more complicated types of behaviors,
as we get more aware of it,
we need a larger set of tools to change those types of behaviors.
We need more forces.
Now this,
this framework is something that I put together based on decades of scientific
research from other scientists and psychologists and from our own work,
I've found that this works across a number of different areas.
We've,
we've used it,
I'm in the medical school and we've used it and apply it to people at risk for
diseases where we need to change help.
I found that it works in my own life for personal behaviors and,
and it works in business work that I do too.
So,
so this gives you a high level overview and,
and if there's,
there's more questions that the book goes into a lot more detail about this
framework
and what I want to do now,
the purpose of this talk,
I want to leave you guys with understanding the difference between a,
B and c behaviors.
So what I'd like to do now as a,
a type of Q and a is have someone come up here,
uh,
and we'll talk about whether your behaviors and a B or c behavior.
But,
but first let's everyone pull out your cards that we had at the beginning and
raise your hand if you wrote down in a behavior.
Okay.
Raise your hand if you wrote down a bee behavior.
I think so.
Half hands.
Halfway.
I think so.
Good.
What are,
what's,
what's the BB behavior?
Coughing.
Brushing the teeth.
That lunchtime.
Okay.
And uh,
and see behavior.
Great.
So what's it,
what's the c behavior you had making music?
Making music.
Excellent.
That's one after my own heart.
Um,
all right,
so,
so let's,
let's say just to settle it in and make sure we understand the difference.
Let's call,
call someone up.
Can I get a,
a brave volunteered to come up here and walk through it?
All right,
thanks for coming up here Chris.
Sure.
So tell us about,
tell us about your behavior.
I'm really into dark chocolate and um,
unfortunately I'm into it in,
at nighttime and the darker the better.
So I tend to eat it before I go to bed and then I fall asleep until three
o'clock on that.
I'm like,
I'm up.
So it's a pretty common behavior,
but sometimes it feels burning.
Like I just have to have it cause I get a lift sometimes I can get a little work
done.
Excellent.
So you're already,
you're already thinking about,
so here's a,
here's a chart I was going to ask.
Do we think it's it in a B or c behavior?
So if it's done without awareness.
So the behavior he mentioned was,
you know,
late night snacks and eating chocolate at,
at nighttime.
If it's done without awareness,
I mean my guests,
I'm with you.
My guess is that it's a c behavior,
but let's,
let's just go through for example.
So it would be an a behavior.
If you're not even aware,
you're,
you're almost either sleepwalking or you're just going in there grabbing
chocolate.
Um,
it sounds like you're,
you're aware of what you're doing when you,
I always know what I'm doing.
You know what you want that chocolate tell keep me away from the chocolate.
Yeah.
It would be a behavioral,
is it,
does it feel almost like an addiction?
Does it feel like you can't stop yourself?
Um,
when I'm really stressed out,
it feels like I can't stop myself.
When you're really,
when you're really stressed out,
you can't do it.
Okay.
And in general,
in general,
it's uh,
it's something where you're aware of what you're doing,
but it's just,
there are other things that are,
that are,
you know,
it's driving you toward it.
You're,
you're aware of what you're doing,
but you really want the chocolate and feel like you should eat it.
Well it tastes good and I get a lift.
So then I would,
I would call that a common behavior too.
But it's,
it's,
uh,
this is a good example because some behaviors based on the person or based on
the behavior,
it can be in different categories and we're,
we'll use different solutions to address it.
So.
So let's talk about how to address it.
Let's go back to go back to here.
So as you'll see,
common behaviors community has three stars.
So that makes it really important.
If we can,
if we can,
community,
that'll help out a lot.
So the question is,
do you live with anyone?
I do.
You do?
Okay.
Yeah.
Uh,
so does the person who you live with,
do they,
do they also eat chocolate?
She's a lot of sugar at night,
so,
um,
so I feel like I'm a little more disciplined than she is,
but she doesn't have any issues with it.
You know,
she can just have her sweet stuff and she'll go to sleep.
But,
so that's,
you guys see the challenge that's confronted.
That's one of the difficult parts.
You know,
if you're living with someone,
um,
and that person has no problem with the behavior that they're doing and you have
a problem when you're doing it,
it can make it difficult.
So,
you know,
so one,
this is where,
where,
uh,
discussions come in and,
and would she be,
would she be willing to change?
Would she be willing?
Could you have this discussion with her?
Were both of you guys could,
could,
uh,
slow down or stop eating late night chocolate?
And if not,
it's fine.
If the answer's no,
we can,
but that's a first solution.
Well,
I mean she tends to stay up later and watch TV so we could have hours where she
eats her stuff.
My
got it.
Okay.
So it sounds like,
so that's,
that's a more difficult one.
Um,
but,
but what we can do is so easy.
It's very important.
Uh,
is there a way for you to be able,
it sounds like she eats or sweets,
but for you it's chocolate.
Is there a way for you to either just get the chocolate out of the house,
not have chocolate around?
Well,
I've,
I've moved it out of the office into the pantry.
Sorry,
I have to go downstairs to do it.
So excellent.
It's further away.
Excellent.
So,
so that's an example of,
of being able,
if it's further away,
then it's going to be harder to do.
It's not going to be as easy and you'll be less likely to do it.
And has that hat,
how's that worked out for you?
It's less than the intake.
Great.
So the next step would be,
can you get it out of the house completely?
Uh,
I don't want to do that.
I don't really want to,
but,
um,
I can't for periods of time and then I feel like I have to sort of just read.
I just have to have so,
so,
so if you can,
if you can make it where you have to go to the store in order to get the
chocolate,
that'll,
that'll lessen the amount of,
of chocolate that you're eating.
That's it.
A simple one that definitely makes it easy.
Um,
there also,
if you could put,
are there other kinds of foods that you would like that you can put other than
chocolate you can make closer to you.
So when you're sitting around watching TV,
can you put food in front of you other than chocolate that you would eat?
And we'd just fill you up.
I like fruit that won't,
that won't keep you away.
Great.
So,
so that's another example of,
of how we can use easy,
we can do this in a,
in a gradual process.
Like don't just necessarily throw all the chocolate out of the house if you
don't think that will work.
But you can start with just putting fruit in front of you and eating the fruit
or other food,
um,
in what you'll find is that as that becomes a routine,
it'll become ingrained in grand in your brain every day you'll start doing it
and it'll become a neuro hack.
So you might think,
I'm not capable of stopping myself from eating chocolate.
But as you see day after day that you're eating fruit,
instead,
you'll realize there's nothing wrong with me.
It's not like I'm just wired to have to have this chocolate.
Um,
but you're capable of doing it and it will reset your brain and reset your
behavior.
So,
so these are,
these are the ways of,
of incorporating the science of lasting change.
And,
and uh,
just this is uh,
a quick,
a quick example of a,
of a stick with it session.
So let's all give Chris a hand for coming up here,
being great for doing that.
Thanks so much Chris.
All right now,
now before we,
before we end off,
I'm after all,
I'm a teacher so I can't have you guys leave here without giving you an
assignment.
Now just buy just for showing up here today,
you guys are,
have already activated some of the important important forces for lasting change
and,
and being able to change the behavior that you wrote down.
And what we want to do is,
is keep that energy going,
keep,
keep the motivation going and keep,
keep the forces so,
so with this take home,
this take home assignment,
this is something to do immediately to do today.
What I want you to do is take the behavior that you wrote down on the card and I
want you to to tell someone else.
You could tell,
it could be a coworker,
it could be a friend,
could be a romantic partner,
it could be a stranger.
I want you to tell them,
do you think the behaviors that a,
B or c behavior and why,
why do you think that?
And just by going through this process of discussing it with them,
it helps to reinforce in your head.
It will teach you to how to,
to know the difference and will keep the energy going.
Second eye,
please email me and let me know.
You can reach me at Sean Young,
phd.com or on Twitter at Sean Young,
Phd.
Tell me whether you think it's an a,
B or c behavior and why.
Now I went into this,
this area because I really wanted to,
to be able to have an impact on the world and to help people so,
so please reach out to me.
I really want to,
to be able to try to help with this.
Now before I,
before I finish off,
I've good news to share.
Going back to the story of my brother,
he in the year since then,
my brother has,
he's changed his behavior.
He really healthy eating,
he exercises,
he
takes his medication,
he does everything that you supposed to do and best of all these really healthy.
He's,
he's been feeling great and he's been doing really well and since he's my
brother I can pretend to take some credit for that.
So I'm going to leave you guys and,
and if,
if the information in here,
if this was helpful,
if you like this,
hopefully,
hopefully you learn something and enjoyed it.
If you did,
there's this great book out here that you guys can all read that will give you
more info about it.
You're laughing at this.
Pick my favorite.
I think my favorite thing about this picture is that it makes me wonder the
other photographer was a cat wearing a GoPro.
The squat at the top.
We often,
when we're trying to do things,
we think that if we can't do it,
it's because we're not motivated enough cause we're not inspired.
We don't have enough willpower,
but those are temporary feelings.
They come and they go,
so we can't have behaviors last just based on inspiration.
What we need is to have a process that doesn't matter how we're feeling at the
time.
We'll be able to follow that process.
So that's where I say motivation,
inspiration,
and willpower are temporary feelings.
The secret to sticking with something is to use a process that you can follow no
matter how you feel.
You guys have been a great audience.
Thank you so much for your,
I look forward to here.